[Music]
good hello Chucky I almost brought my
Chucky doll and then I thought well that
would be kind of dorky but I guess it
had the same thought is it dorky uh I
think these people will excuse it yeah
so I've got
I've got buns Jennifer Tilly it's a lot
of fun
um both on screen and off as you can
imagine I mean you don't even really
have to imagine and you can just like
watch her Instagram feed and see how how
fun she is in real life but yeah it's
great having her around I mean one of
the things that's been we've been
talking about recently it's been nice
about having now two consecutive seasons
of a TV show
it keeps us all in shape you know we're
all you know rather than like doing a
movie and then we're down for a few
years and come back it's like all of us
you know the actors the puppeteers the
writers my fellow directors you know
everyone's in shape and so it's
um it's I think good for the good for
the show it's good creatively but
Jennifer getting back to original
question she also sees to it that we
have a very rigorous social schedule
outside of the show like on our days off
is she like the social butterfly of the
group
she is a bit of the cruise director yeah
like what's that character from Love
Boat Julie Julie was the actress anyway
you know yeah
so in season two the kids are sent to a
Catholic School does this have any sort
of significance to you were you sent to
Catholic school as a kid I was raised
Catholic yes
um I didn't go to Catholic solo
ironically I once when the Episcopalian
school starting in eighth grade
um but you know I went to Sunday school
I mean like communion
um but but before I made my confirmation
I got sent to this Episcopalian school I
mean because they were great
scholastically but also also
athletically which was important to my
parents because I was a runner
um
but it was really there that I first
learned about a lot of
a lot of the intricacies of the Catholic
faith that I hadn't learned
such as the concept of
transubstantiation I don't know if you
know what that is but in Catholic mass
when the priest blesses the communion
host and the wine a literal Miracle
happens it is not a symbolic thing the
it turns literally miraculously into the
Flesh of Christ and to the blood of
Christ and I wasn't aware that we
believed such an outrageously
Supernatural thing and I was fascinated
by that
of course suddenly I brought into a lot
of things into question and it was it
was good for me because I was like
starting to take classes in church
history and stuff and learning about the
creation of Western faiths and stuff
like that and it helped me it helped me
become the lapsed Catholic I am today
we're bringing you a metaphorical verse
version of my Adventures as a young gay
kid you know that is that what brought
you into the horror genre I mean that's
pretty horrible that's part of it sure
yeah I mean because the Catholic church
is Rife with incredibly dramatic
horrifying rituals and symbols and
stories yes absolutely it's a horror
show
wow I managed to escape all of that
um and Chucky seems almost more
threatening when he's not killing and I
only saw there was a mess up with my
account and I only saw episode two of
the new season so far so but he seemed
like as a scout he was almost more
um threatening when he's just kind of
sneaking around is how how do you manage
that I mean is it
with this season because we had left off
with the notion of
72 separate Chuckies on the back of that
truck and wondering what became of any
or all of them it gave us the
opportunity to create mystery you know
which which is important you know the
idea of like bringing a Chucky into the
situation and clocking that he's up to
something new that just that's just
interesting I think right you know
rather than just jumping right into the
old slice and dice we know of course
that he's going to get to that but if
there's something else going on it's
like ah I think I want to tune in
another week to find out what he's up to
so what else is he up to then
um well I can't say anything too
specific but you know he's he's up to
Revenge certainly that's his stated his
stated goal is that he wants revenge on
everyone who forwarded him at the end of
last season so it's those kids but also
Tiffany mm-hmm
um and so that's interesting because it
puts Tiffany in a defensive position as
opposed to the very in control
place she was in season one I wanted to
put the character in a new place and I
wanted to give Jennifer something new to
play
what else can we expect from this season
um I think you can expect you know lots
of bloody doll Mayhem uh
you know Chucky intersecting with nuns
and Priests and various Catholic rights
rituals
and all of the paraphernalia that goes
with that
um you know you're going to see some
homages to other uh horror movies in
that genre like the Exorcist and The
Omen and stuff like that has there been
any sort of outcry from religious groups
who are you know upset that they're
bringing in you're you're introducing
Chucky into the into the Catholic church
or
are are
the church is just kind of used to this
by now
probably the latter I can't I mean I
haven't heard any any complaints I
wouldn't surprise me if there were but
it wouldn't surprise me if like this is
you know chicken I think we're just like
a gnat on the shoulder of the Catholic
church it's easily flicked away probably
but also I didn't I didn't want to be I
didn't want it to be too easy and
simplistic I don't I didn't I don't want
to make the church
merely the bad guy I think that would be
too simple and I think you know we've
got some religious characters in the
story who were people that were rooting
for in the story
um so I I thought that that was
important too because I like
you know I I have plenty of angst as a
as a gay man who came out of the
Catholic church but on the other hand I
do acknowledge you know there are lots
of good people in the church and that
they have done some good things etc etc
you know any kind of real you know
incredibly powerful religious
institution I mean they do some good
works
well great well thank you so much and I
really look forward to watching the rest
of the season
thank you Don